[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you very much
first of all
madam president chaputova
prime minister hegal dear edward
prime minister
karen
kristianis what a pleasure to see you
here and i see the prime minister of
georgia too
ladies and gentlemen excellencies
before i start to reflect
on what we heard from president
zielenski
i want to thank
this
country slovakia
for your
generosity and solidarity with the
ukrainian refugees you're receiving here
it's almost 700 000
you've opened your hearts you've opened
your minds
history will never forget
your gratitude your solidarity and the
shining example you are so many many
thanks for that
we have just heard president zielenski
and it has been now
15 weeks
that
russia has invaded ukraine an innocent
neighbor
and we have learned so much
about the tenacity
of the ukrainian soul
the people of ukraine have found courage
and adversity we've just listened again
and witnessed again that and strength in
each other
and even as this brutal bumping and
shelling is going on
they've never left hope
they
have never lost sight
of what it is all about
it is about shaping the future of
ukraine
and the question indeed how would will
ukraine look like in 5 or 10 or 15 years
and the
impressive element in it is that the
ukrainian people know exactly
what they want their country to be
they want freedom
they want sovereignty
they want security
they want to fulfill the incredible
potential of this beautiful country
they want to shape their future the
future on their own
and they want to be part of our european
family
and they will at no
cost let kremlin stand in their way
i think
this ukrainian resolve
is really inspiring for the whole world
i was like you madam president
in kiev
right before easter in bucha
i've
met
survivors who were barely able to find
words for what they have suffered
i've seen the mass graves
i've seen the body bags
lined up next to a church
i have seen this
trail of blood and destruction
caused by the russian army
and yet
the ukrainians people desire to resume
their lives after that terror is
stronger than anything else
in just one month
they built a new railway bridge
reconnecting
the two towns
to kiev
and the situation is still dire without
any question
but they are taking back their towns
they are taking back their lives
disrespect of what is happening on the
ground and this is so impressive
ukrainians want to return to the path
that leads towards the future they dream
of
towards a prosperous ukraine
a peaceful country
and i want all of them to know
that our european union stands by their
side
we will do everything possible in our
power
so that ukrainians can once again be the
masters of their own future
first
we have to support them to overcome this
war
second they badly need financial relief
and third
we have to accompany ukrainians in
pursuing their path towards the european
union and these are the very practical
three topics i want to speak about
ladies and gentlemen
ukrainians must win this war
and putin
must
witness
that for him it is a severe strategic
failure
it must be clear
that invading a sovereign country comes
with a massive price tag for the
aggressor
we are all standing up for ukraine
and therefore we are not only providing
military aid to a country under attack
i see here the leaders in the room and i
know of your work here in this field in
bilateral support of military equipment
but also the european level for the
first time ever in our history
is providing financial support for
buying military equipment for the
ukrainians
we are mobilizing our full economic
power
putin has mobilized his armed forces
we are mobilizing our economic power
with the powerful sanctions
that we have imposed
we have imposed economic sanctions on
any kind of goods that might
be necessary for modernizing or
diversifying the russian economy and
these sanctions are biting they're
grinding their teeth into the russian
economy
we're paralyzing the russian central
bank's capacity
to raise capital
we're cutting off russian banks from the
swift system
we are getting rid and we have to get
rid of our dependency of russian fossil
fuels
this is
the deepest cut
we can do
to the russian economy because the
russian economy is not a very modern
economy it's not a very diversified
economy but it is a economy based on
fossil fuels so if we want to hit
the kremlin's war chest
if we want
to drain
poutine's war chest then we have to get
rid of our dependency on russian fossil
fuels we have gotten rid of coal already
we are working hard now to ban up to 90
percent of
russian oil
and we have to get rid of russian gas
and for that
distinguished
ladies and gentlemen
we have put out our plan our roadmap
this is repower eu
it's a plan of 300 billion euros
that is composed of on one hand energy
saving that sounds so simple but it's a
powerful tool
if we would only lower
in
the heating for example two degrees
celsius or if there is an air
conditioning
increase it by two degrees celsius
in the european union
this is the whole supply
we're getting through north stream one
at the moment being russian gas only two
degrees
everybody can contribute everybody can
give his or her share
to reduce the dependency on russian gas
second we have to diversify away
from russia and russian gas to our
trustworthy and reliable suppliers like
for example the united states but also
others so we've now formed a joint
platform to purchase together
gas elsewhere in the world because we
know we also have as 27 a huge market
power
and the third topic
is the most important one
that is we have to massively invest
in renewable energy
renewable energy we all know it's good
to fight climate change
but it is also good
to fight
the kremlin's aggression against ukraine
because renewable energy
will replace
russian gas
every single kilowatt hour we get from
solar wind biomass you name it hydrogen
is
a kilowatt hour that we will be reducing
our dependency
on russian fossil fuels
and therefore we know that renewable
energy as i said is not only good for
our climate it is also good for our
independence
and it is also good for our security
energy our supply
and they are homegrown
and they create
good and quality jobs here in the
european union
and then we have to do everything
possible
to support
ukraine
to keep up its economy
according to the united nations
ukraine's economy output might fall by
50 percent this year
yet millions of ukraine still
need to make their living
so to support them
we have suspended all duties and all
quotas on ukrainian goods
and we are setting up solidarity lanes
now
to try to get out of the country as much
wheat or cereals or corn and
agricultural products as we can
because you know that putin is blocking
the export of wheat
via the black sea
it is atrocious to see that that
deliberately deliberately putin is
blocking the wheat supply of the world
50 of the world food program
comes from ukraine's wheat we
desperately need that weed but he's
making
his he's driving his war
um
in taking not the slightest
responsibility for being the one who one
day has to stand up for the fact that
people are dying of hunger and famine
will be big again and hunger will be a
driving motor again in the world
he is deliberately bombarding warehouses
with ukrainian wheat at the moment being
we have 20 million tons of ukrainian
wheat stuck in ukraine so we have to do
everything to get it out via our green
lanes
this is not trivial
but it is absolutely worth every single
effort
we know that ukraine could literally
feed the world
about two-thirds of the country are
covered with the so-called black earth
one of the most fertile souls soils of
the world
and
there's this beautiful ukrainian flag
which symbolizes the yellow fields
under blue blue sky
this is ukraine and we want this ukraine
to have a future
and this leads me
to my third point
that is economic support
and reconstruction
ukraine needs economic
and financial support now
we know that at the moment being ukraine
needs per month 5 billion euros
just to make it
to pay the pensions
to pay the salaries
to have basic services
continuing like health service for
example
so we need to set up a mechanism
that there is the basic support
financial support of around about five
billion euros per month for ukraine
g7 started
and put out nine billion already seven
and a half billion of those are from our
american friends
and one billion from germany in grants
we the european level
proposed now to match this
and to put up an extraordinary macro
financial assistance we're discussing
that in the european council but this is
the minimum we can do to support ukraine
to make it through the next month
financially
but what is
also as important as the now
is that we start to think and president
zielinski did it on screen
that we start to think
now about reconstructing this beautiful
country ukraine
and for that
we want to build a platform
and president celinski spoke partially
about it we want to create a platform
where all these initiatives that are out
there
be it for example from our american
friends but also world bank imf oecd g20
you name it bilateral countries
all these initiatives and
financial support
are channeled on a platform
where we together
decide on the direction to travel
this platform is led and owned by
ukraine because it's ukraine who decides
on its future
but together with them
we want to engage
in from the very beginning on
to shape this platform in a way
that we have
investment
with reform
the european commission
will stand by ukrainian side with all
the track record we have with all the
experience we have
to help them that the investment is
effective combined with the necessary
reforms that then will of course pave
the way into the european union
it is for us important that there are
reforms on the
administrative capacity for example
on a strong rule of law
on an independent judiciary
always the fight against corruption
but also creating a conducive
environment
for the business sector so that
investors
have confidence and trust and come back
and invest in ukraine
ukrainians are fighting so bravely
because they know exactly what kind of
future they want
a future
of a free and open society
belonging to a strong democratic
community
they want to join the european union
we've heard it over and over again i
think
it's not only our strategic interests
but it is our moral duty to make it
possible that they join our european
union and that we pave the path towards
our union
[Applause]
and let me tell you why i think it is so
important to combine investment and
reform
because of course our standards and
conditions
in an eu accession process
must be met
there is neither a wild card nor
shortcut
but how fast
how quickly
how the speed of that such a process is
this is depending on the country itself
and our support
and i'll never forget
prime minister dear edward that you told
me
what a change it made in slovakia
when the country at a certain point in
time
decided to be serious about the
accession of process towards the
european union and then you told me that
the european commission sent expertise
advice a team that worked with you day
and night to do the reforms that were
necessary of course there was a certain
amount of investment
and you made it within a few years
and this is important
once again no shortcuts no wildcard
standards and conditions have to be met
because this is true for all of us in
the european union and we know on a
daily basis how hard it is to keep these
standards up among us 27.
so that has to be
but it's up to us how much we support
how much we invest and it's in the hands
of our ukrainian friends
what they are making out of it
and ladies and gentlemen
after all
i always think when i listen to
president zielenski and all our
ukrainian friends
and the last days i met many young
people from ukraine young delegates from
ukraine
ukraine's longing
and its aspirations
are basically
a reflection of what we have achieved
together
over the past 77
years and if i may pick up the words
that president zelensky spoke i think it
was the last question on the
responsibility he has he said this is
not a burden
this is a great responsibility
and this should be our motto
supporting ukraine on its path towards
the european union it is not a burden
it is our historic responsibility long
live europe's lava ukrainian
[Laughter]
[Applause]